Stahl: Hi. Welcome to
Life of a Google API developer.
My name is Mark Stahl,
and I'm here with
Tony and--Aiuto,
and David Gibson, some engineers
with my team at Google,
and we're gonna be talking
about what it takes to start--
getting started developing
for, uh, using APIs at Google.
So, uh, just a little bit
of procedural information
to get us started--
if you're going
to be Tweeting,
we have a couple hashtags
we'd like you to use
so we can see what
everybody's saying about us,
and we're also using a new
service that will let you
give you--give some feedback
after the session,
so you can tell us
how you like it or whatever.
So these links will be available
after the end of the talk,
so feel free to, you know,
not copy them down
right at this moment.
So, uh, just a brief outline of
what we're gonna cover today--
First, I'm gonna do
a little background,
so you know who this--
this talk is geared to.
This is a 101-level talk,
and, you know,
people who are just getting
started developing APIs.
So in that spirit,
we're actually going
to build an application.
We're gonna walk you
through the process
that a new developer,
uh, dare I say,
a little cowboy programmer
might use
in order to sort of
go through the process
of actually trying out,
learning the APIs,
and actually developing them
and getting a working sample.
Finally, we're gonna
take a little deep dive
into one of the newer pieces
called the APIs Console,
and we're gonna talk about
how you're gonna
manage your projects.
So we've introduced a concept
of a project at Google,
and this is how you
establish a relationship,
and you get a little bit
of feedback on your traffic.
So, uh, and then we'll just
do a little wrap-up and Q&A.
So starting with the background,
this talk is a beginner talk.
It is a 101-level session,
so we have--we make
some assumptions
that you are familiar with Java,
you know how to program,
but, uh,
we do not assume you have
any particular experience
with Google APIs.
We also sort of--we're gonna
take the position of a developer
who likes to sort of dive in,
learn,
and sort of learn
by experimentation.
While we say that this talk
is built around Java,
uh, just so you know,
the concepts you learn here
should apply to any language,
so if you're working--
coming from another language,
don't be discouraged.
You'll still get a lot
out of this talk.
So also, I'd like to talk
a little bit about
which APIs we're
talking about here.
At Google, we have many APIs.
Some--I don't know, I've heard
the number 80 bantered around.
You can go to this--
you can go to our, web, uh,
code web site
and see the actual number.
We're talking here
about the RESTful APIs.
Uh, about a year ago
when we talked,
most people didn't know
what RESTful was,
or it was still growing
in importance.
These days, REST
is pretty well understood.
They're very simple and easy
APIs to use.
They are built basically
straight on the HTTP protocol,
so you'll use HTTP verbs
to manipulate
what they call resources,
and a resource
is usually just a document
living at some well-known URL,
and in our case,
all our documents, uh,
we recommend these days,
are written in JSON.
All of our new APIs have a--
all of our APIs
are now being built
on a common infrastructure.
Last year, at Google I/O,
we did a presentation,
a little behind-the-scenes look
at how Google builds APIs.
And if you want to listen to me
speak a lot more,
you're willing to go to that URL
and check out, uh,
a little bit more
about how we build APIs.
And it'll also give you
a much better introduction
to what RESTful architecture is.
So, uh, in the last year,
we've introduced
several new APIs
on this new infrastructure.
Uh, today, we'll be taking--
we'll be using the Buzz API,
and the URL Shortener API,
but there are some,
I don't know, 13 APIs now,
are out on that
infrastructure as of today,
a lot more
as of this morning.
And, uh, you can go
check them all out,
see what's available.
In this talk,
I'm also gonna introduce
several of the new tools
that we've introduced
in the past year.
As a developer,
you're gonna find these tools
very helpful with getting
started with developing,
uh, for APIs.
The first tool that you'll all
probably want to really know
is, we call
the APIs Explorer.
This will allow you
to sort of play with APIs
and learn about them,
and I'll introduce that
a little later.
We're also going
to present the AP--
the Java client library
that we're releasing--
that we've released--
and we're going to spend
a lot of time delving
into the API Console,
which is where developers, uh,
live at Google.
So let's start right in
on our core task.
We're going to start
building an application.
And anybody who's built
an application, you know,
some people say that a lot
of the best applications happen
because everybody has
a personal itch to scratch,
So the first thing we need to do
is find our inspiration.
What is it that--
that bothers us,
or what we think
we can do better?
What is not being done today?
So let's start
with a personal one
that I find kind of annoying.
Here's a list--
a link that takes me
to my particular Buzz posts.
So if we go to this screen,
you can see all the Buzz posts
that I, or, you know,
I, the Google API
developer/user, have made.
And, you know, there's a couple
little entries here,
and each one is accompanied
by one of these very long URLs,
and so it sort of occurs to me,
as a programmer that, you know,
wouldn't it be nice if--
let's see if I can get this
to change slides.
That would be good.
Wouldn't it be nice to have
these URLs be nice, short URLs,
clean up my Buzz posts a lot?
Now, of course, I could just
shorten my URLs manually.
So every time I post a Buzz,
I go to the browser,
I've got the URL,
I go to a URL shortener tool,
or I have a little hot button,
and I take the shortened URL
and paste it in.
So I can manually
do all this work,
but, you know,
it would be really nice
if Buzz were to sort of
auto-shorten my URLs for me,
but, of course,
Buzz doesn't do that--
at least not yet.
So, uh, I--but then I realized
there are APIs for these things,
so, you know,
I can build the app for that.
At least, I think I can.
So this is what
I'm gonna build.
Today, we're gonna walk you
through building
a URL shortening agent that
just watches your Buzz feed
and cleans up your URLs for you.
So, uh, in order to know whether
or not we can build this
using APIs--of course,
now is the point where
we're gonna want to dive in
and learn about the APIs,
and see whether or not
they can do what--
what we're trying
to achieve today.
So first step, of course,
all good developers do,
is they sit down and they read
the documentation
from end to end, right?
Yeah--so, not true. [laughs]
Then we have some
really great documentation,
great reference guides.
You're gonna want
to get into that eventually,
but, you know,
a much better step 0
would be just to go try them out
and get familiar with them
and see what they can do.
So, uh, to that end,
we have built a tool
that will really help you
get started,
and we are introducing this tool
in the last few months,
we launched
the Google APIs Explorer.
So this is a web-based tool.
It lists all the APIs
that we currently support
on the new infrastructure,
and it allows you to make
these requests
and actually see the responses.
And when I say "make the request
and see the response,"
you can actually see
all the HTTP interexchanges
that are going on,
and this will really help you
when you're trying
to learn about,
and most importantly,
debug your applications.
'Cause you can actually
make the mistakes in the API--
the same ones
you might make programming--
you can see how
the systems respond,
and you can sort of learn how
to adapt and how to fix them,
and actually work
until you get the--
the correct responses.
And we also
support authentication,
so a lot of the APIs require you
to be authenticated
before you can actually
access private data.
The web API Explorer
supports that,
so we can actually do
everything in the API Explorer
that any real application
can do.
So let's go take a look at it.
The API Explorer lives
on the code site--
code.google.com,
and here's--this is the URL,
and let's go check that out.
So we start up here
with this screen.
This shows you a list of APIs
that are available
in the service,
and as I said,
that's a fairly large list.
I don't know
the exact number offhand,
but it's growing a lot right--
right around Google I/O.
And, uh, we'll start here
with the Buzz API,
so let's select that.
And you see, there's only
one version available,
and we have a nice link to that,
the documentation,
so when you're ready for reading
a little bit more in depth,
that's where you're gonna go.
And here's every
method and operation
that you can do
in the Buzz API.
As you can see,
the Buzz API is--
well, that's quite
a long list of things,
so let's start with the ones
that are most important
to the application
we're trying to build.
First thing we need to do is get
a list of our Buzz activities,
which are all those great posts
I showed you in my feed.
So here's one.
This is called activity list.
And we click that,
and here's a list
of all the parameters
that I can pass into that.
Now, uh, I'm--first of all,
the parameters here
shown with the asterisk
are the required parameters,
so there's two here
that I have to do,
which is the user I.D.--
who am I actually accessing?
And that--
that's gonna be myself,
so, uh, I do know
that there's a token--
from reading
some documentation--
that there's a token
called "at me,"
and that--
and that tells me that--
to use whoever is
the authenticated user,
who's actually
making the request.
That's the person whose
activities I'm going to list.
Next is, I'm gonna want
to set the scope.
The scope is a description of,
once I've--the activity list
allows you to list
different types
of activity events,
and there's actually a whole
bunch of different groups--
groupings that you
can choose from.
The one that I'm looking for
is the self group,
which is the group of activities
that I myself have posted,
as opposed to comments,
activities that other people
have done,
or things that I'm receiving
from other people.
So this is the self scope.
Next, you can see
there's a lot of alt--
uh, parameters that are optional
that I can supply.
Uh, "alt equals JSON"--
this one is hard-wired
into the Explorer,
so you're getting
JSON responses.
And I'm gonna say, oh,
I only want to get
the max results the first ten,
so now I've constructed
a request in the Explorer.
Let's execute it
and see how it looks in HTTP.
So, ah!
very first thing that happens
is I get an error.
Um, before I look at the error,
let's look at just
the request itself.
You can see right here
on the URL,
this is an actual HTTP request
being issued by an Explorer,
and this is the API.
It's very simple.
So you can see in here,
there's a URL,
Google APIs,
where all requests go.
You can see that I'm accessing
Buzz version 1.
I'm accessing
the activities feed.
The required parameters
you can see right here,
"at me" and "at self," which we
talked about a second ago.
And you can also see a lot
of these optional parameters--
the JSON, max results, pp--
that's prettyprint,
so we have readable output,
and, uh, key,
which we will cover later.
And we just--all this was just
done with the HTTP Get request.
That's it.
That's the API.
Um, and there's a small
user agent, of course,
and here, I can see the response
that I got back.
In this case,
I got a 401 unauthorized,
and that, uh, the Explorer
itself has warned me,
"This method requires you
to be authenticated."
Obviously, we forgot
to authenticate.
And it even tells me, you need
to switch to private access,
which I'll show you in a second,
so let's go try switching
to private access.
I can close the history pane
and go back to this.
Now up in the Explorer,
you see here, it says,
"using public access."
I'm not actually
logged in as anybody,
or have any authorization.
I'm gonna use, uh,
switch to private access.
I'm gonna be using something
called OAuth,
or, in this case, OAuth2,
which is the second version
of the OAuth protocol,
and I'm going to grant me
as the person making the--
as the user of the API Explorer.
I'm going to grant to
the API Explorer application
the permission to make
requests on my behalf.
So in Google--
in order to do that,
the API Explorer's gonna
generate a request to Google,
Google's gonna show me
a little dialogue,
and I'm gonna click that there.
Uh, I'll show that in a sec,
but first, I have to choose
also the scope.
The scope is, uh, a list of--
when I grant ath--
when I grant authorization
to this application,
the application
is going to request
a certain amount of power.
How much does--
how much authorization
does it really want?
And in this case,
the Buzz, uh, scope,
is what we call it--
the Buzz scope says
"The APIs Explorer application
is requesting ability
to read and write
all my Buzz feeds,"
to pretty much have
full control.
There's also another scope
called Buzz read-only,
you can see,
that is, if the API Explorer
is going to choose--
only has the ability
to read things,
but not to write them back.
There's a Picasso one,
which limits you more
to the photo sets of the API,
and so when every API publishes
a certain set of scopes
that it supports,
and as the developer,
you actually choose the scope.
Normally, you know,
in the Explorer, of course,
we let--we let me, the user,
choose the scope, but normally,
you as the developer
are gonna choose the scope,
and really, you want
to choose the scope
that's the least powerful,
so you don't scare your users
by asking for too much.
But in this case,
I need to read and write,
so I'm using the Buzz scope.
And I'll switch
to private access,
and a little window pops up,
so here, it says,
"Google APIs Explorer is
requesting permission to manage
all my Buzz activities"--
exactly what I want.
Here's a small detail
of the types of things
I'm giving it permission to do,
and a little bit
more infi--info,
which tells me, you know,
who wrote this application,
and, uh, where the redirect
is gonna go after it's done.
So, of course,
I want to allow access,
and now you'll see that it says
here on the APIs Explorer,
"using private access,"
so let's try
this same request again.
Ah! this time,
you can see that it--
executed moments ago,
I actually executed the request.
I now have a new authorization
header, using OAuth,
with a very large
complicated token,
and I got back an ok--
a response.
This is a 200.
Uh, I can actually see in
this response all the headers
that I got back--again,
a really great debugging tool--
and the JSON body.
Here it is.
So you can see here, uh,
there's one of
my object contents.
This is the actual
object content.
This is my Buzz post right here.
"Stormy weather
for Amazon Cloud services."
Oh, that's probably not
politically correct, so...
Anyway, uh, this is just
an example.
Let's go back to this tool.
Um, so just a little bit more
about the APIs Explorer
before I go on.
Uh, Google launched--
just yesterday,
we introduced a new API.
We call it the Google APIs
Discovery Service,
and it provides a list
of all APIs,
and a mechanical,
machine-readable description
of how they operate.
And, uh, this service--if you
want to learn more about it,
you can go see a talk tomorrow--
at 10:00 in the morning,
there's a presentation
just on this API,
and how we use it to construct
client libraries.
We also use it to construct
things like the API Explorer.
The Explorer itself
is a completely
dynamically driven service,
so anytime Google launches
a new API
on the APIs infrastructure,
it shows up in Explorer,
and you can play with it.
So it's a really cool tool,
and I invite you all
to check it out
if you're interested.
So let's go back
to the next step.
So just to recap
what I've done so far,
using the Explorer,
I was actually able to show
all the behaviors
that I wanted to show,
so you're actually now ready
to start programming
against, uh, the actual APIs.
However, uh,
I'm actually a manager.
I don't actually get time
to write code, but I have--
you know, I'm in Google,
there are a lot
of great engineers here,
and, in fact,
Tony's one of them.
He's gonna come up and actually
show you how to program the API.
Tony.
Aiuto: Thank you, Mark.
Uh, good morning, everyone.
Uh, so to begin,
I have to get my tools in order,
and the primary tool I need
is a client library.
Uh, we have libraries
that we've recently enhanced
in the last few months.
We have them for
these five popular languages.
We have more coming.
They all share common idioms,
and they're all open-sourced
and live on code.google.com.
Um, this is just a landing page
for the thing.
You could browse here
for documentation
and pointers to each.
Each has its own site
devoted to its own examples
and, uh, sample classes.
Um, today, we're going
to use Java.
I, uh, hope that's
appropriate for this audience.
Um, but the things I teach you
will be applicable
to any language, should you
choose something else.
Um,
whoops--slide.
Oops, too far.
The--I'd like to talk about
the Google APIs client for Java.
Um, this is now
in version 1.4 Beta.
At the bottom is a base library
that provides mechanisms
for building HTTP requests,
um, creating and parsing
those, uh, responses
in JSON and XML,
and OAuth2 helper classes.
The HTTP transport is--
you can plug in
whichever one you want,
because you use different ones
in different environments.
People writing mobile apps
on Android
would probably use the ones
bundled with the Android SDK.
If you're writing
a web server app,
you may use a different one.
Same goes for your JSON
and XML parsers.
Uh, Android uses GSON
very often.
Most people use
the Jackson parser.
They have different memory
and speed footprints.
Authentication you saw
a little of in Mark's talk,
where we had the failure,
and then we had
to give permissions.
That's a complex topic.
We have a lot of helper classes
to make that easier for you.
Above the base library,
we have API specific libraries,
so there is one for Buzz,
URL shorten, moderator.
These are built
with the discovery mechanisms.
In the same way
the APIs Explorer
generates itself on the fly
from discovery,
we can use this to generate
strongly typed Java libraries.
They consist
of a service factory,
which makes the requests
to the service,
and data model classes,
which represent
the actual data elements
that the service provides.
Um, I said these are now
in version 1.4,
announced in Beta this week.
We can go to
the landing page for that
and take a look at what
it is like.
Yeah, from here,
there are links
to the developers' guides,
setup tools,
documentation for both
the base library
and the API-specific libraries,
and samples you need
to get started with.
Um, now,
real program--
oops, didn't click.
Real programmers
don't necessarily
read the documentation.
I'm hoping that I can find
a piece of code
on Google's web site
that'll do roughly what I want,
and I can learn from that
and use it as a base to build
the application that I'd like.
And I am lucky here,
because we do have
samples like that.
So somewhere in the code site
for the API library,
we've found this set
of examples,
and there's things for BigQuery
and Buzz and Calendar.
Uh, more get added.
These are open-source.
We accept contributions
from the crowd.
Uh, I'm going to take
one of these Buzz ones
and do what I would do
with any piece of code
I find on the internet--
I'm gonna load it up, I'm gonna
bit-compile it and run it,
because what could
possibly go wrong?
Um, so let's see,
um, what happens
when I run this piece
that I pulled from Google.
And let's make that
a little bigger.
Eh, we can make it even bigger.
It is running.
It is building a URL
to pop up that
authentication request,
like what we saw
in the APIs Explorer.
It's popped up--ooh,
it popped up the browser window,
and immediately failed,
um, and it's failed
with this message--
"invalid client."
So not totally despondent.
I can go back and do
what real programmers do do,
which is read my comments.
Early on, I see
this block of code,
and these two lines immediately
draw my attention.
They say "enter_client_id"
and "enter_client_secret."
Clearly, these are values
I have to provide.
Fortunately, there are comments
nearby in the code
saying that they come from
the Google APIs console,
and there's a link to the APIs
console sitting there,
so let's follow that link
and see what we have to do
at the console.
We have to start a project.
I guess so. I want
to identify my project.
And I know I want to use Buzz,
so I'm going to do that.
Oh, and I've got
the terms of service agreement
for Buzz, which I think
I will agree to,
so we can proceed.
We'll accept that.
And I also know I'm going to
want to use the URL shortener,
so let's just
accept that now.
Now the comments
were about access,
so I'm going to go
to the API access,
and I need an OAuth2
client I.D.,
so let's create one of those.
My product will be
LOGAD11.
I do not have a logo yet,
because I'm just
a small company.
And I'm going to select
an installed application,
because the app I'm running
is running on my desktop.
It's not on a web server.
Um, a web application would be
something out in the cloud
that you can refer to.
Installed apps
run on your desktop.
Client I.D.
And now I've generated
these three items here.
Client I.D. and client secret--
That sounds good.
It ties in with my code.
A redirect URI,
which is a funny string here--
we'll come back to that.
Oh, those were the elements
we just generated.
I'll go back to my code,
and I will cut
and paste them in.
Now that I've done that,
we can look a little--
these other fields here, uh,
they're also
authentication-related.
The redirect URI you saw
on the, um, APIs console--
that's a special marker
to say this is a native
installed application.
The scope below it,
Mark alluded to
in the APIs console.
It was the write
that we're asking the user
to grant the application.
This is the ability to read
and write my Buzz posts.
And let's see how the sample
looks when we finally run it...
If I can learn to type.
Okay,
we're creating a little local
web server to get a redirect.
We've built
the authorization URL.
That's gonna pop up
the browser window.
And this is great.
We've seen the same kind
of authentication window
that we saw
in the APIs Explorer.
My app here is looking
to manage my Buzz activity.
I will allow it access.
The window closes.
I get a response back
saying it's okay.
Now we're asking
the OAuth server from Google
for a verification code,
and we see one of these strings
that looks very much
like the string we saw
in the APIs Explorer that
was posted into the request.
And now I see my Buzz posts--
or, I see Mark's Buzz posts
listed here.
Great.
At this point, I know
that I can run an application.
So it's time to look
through the sample code,
learn how it works,
and then I can use that
as a base to finish.
Um, early in the code,
I see this.
It's creating a transport level
for the HTTP request
and the JSON parser.
Uh, these are the kind--
these are a pair
that are appropriate
for an installed app.
Right below it, I use those
to create a Buzz object,
and my Buzz object
is going to be my handle
for creating requests
to the Buzz service.
Right below that in the code,
I see this--
we're taking that
client I.D. and secret
that were pasted into the app,
making an identity object,
then using the identity object
and the scope--
so it's my application
and the writes it wants--
to create this, uh,
local server flow object.
This is a helper class
that's provided with the example
that runs through
launching the server
and doing this OAuth dance
and this flow that gets you
the authorization token.
We call that local
server flow object
to get the access token,
and then we call
the Buzz set access token
to brand that into
every future request.
So that's how it slips into
the HTTP headers.
And this sample hides
a lot of the details of OAuth2.
We're trying to make it
easy for you,
but it is a complex subject,
and a little later on
in the talk,
we'll go into that
in much more detail.
I see below this, some code
that actually makes a request.
Here, um, I'm building
an activities list request
by calling this constructor
for it.
You'll see this is identical
to the request Mark's made.
I've passed in me and self,
the two required
parameters to this.
I'm setting the optional
parameter maxResults.
We do our required parameters
in the constructor.
We do our optional parameters,
just a setting
on the request below it.
Finally, I execute that request,
and get a response,
and the response is not
just a block of JSON or XML.
It comes back to you
a fully formed object
that can be of any depth
of complexity as required.
That object happens to have
an array of activities in it,
called the feed items.
I can loop through that array,
take the Buzz object from each,
grab its content,
which is actually my post,
and print it.
Now this idiom
I've just shown you
is used in all of
our client libraries.
We always build a request,
we possibly let you modify it,
we execute the request,
and get results.
So what you've learned
here is applicable
in any language
you want to use.
And I know what I have to know,
so I have to sit down
and start doing the code
to finish my application,
and I'm gonna begin
at the bottom,
writing some of the grunt work
things that I need.
I know I have to go through
a string,
look for URLs, and replace them,
so I wrote
a little replacer, um,
and it works by taking
a block of text
and a regular expression,
letting you iterate
over that block of text
with the next operator.
You can pull out the current
match, see that string,
and replace it with something
else if you choose to.
And finally, when you're done,
you can grab the result
into modified string.
Um, coming up a level,
we're gonna want to make
shortened URLs.
So I'm gonna have to add
the URL shortener
to my--my application.
I've accepted
the terms of service
and turned it on in the console,
so I'm ahead of the game there.
And now I have to add a factory
for building URL shortener
requests to my application,
and it only adds two lines
of code here.
I import the thing, and I
create a URL shortener object.
I'm reusing the same
transport and factory
that I used for the Buzz object,
because they are thread safe
and reusable in that way.
You should only need
one Buzz object,
one URL shortener,
one transport, one factory,
for an application of any comp--
of infinite complexity.
Um, so my inner loop
to create request
looks something like this.
I make one of my replacers.
Out in the code somewhere,
I have this hairy REGEX
that detects URLs.
I run it over a piece of text,
looking for them.
If they're already shortened,
I skip them,
but if I want to shorten it,
I do this,
and this is exactly
what Mark did.
We create the body
of the request,
which is a URL object.
I set the long URL.
I create an insert request
with that body.
Then I execute the request,
and I get a response.
That response has the short
UI dell--I.D.--
short URL in the I.D. field.
I can replace that
into the text,
and after I've iterated
all of them,
I can return the result.
The outer loop that calls this
looks like this.
We iterate over
the activity items
in my activity feed.
I take the content from each.
I shorten them.
If it's changed, I want
to update my Buzz post,
and I do that by creating
an updateRequest
with the required me and self.
I have to give it the I.D.
of the activity
that I'm updating,
and I give it
the modified activity.
I execute that request,
and I get a result.
Let's see if it works.
It's doing
the same OAuth process,
starting the server.
It's filled the URL
we're gonna direct the user to,
and popping up
a browser window for them.
Great.
I see the application.
This time, I've added URL
shortener to my list of scopes,
so I see that.
We're going to grant it access.
We're finishing the OAuth
with a verification code,
turning that into
an access token,
and...
Great. We're going
through the posts.
I see the long URLs.
I see them shortened
to something.
I could declare a victory here,
but really,
I should go check to see
if anything happened,
so let's look
at Mark's Buzz feed.
There we go.
They're all short,
and I'm gonna declare victory
at this point.
Okay, so now I really know
everything I need
to write code.
Um, I know how to create
a handle to an ob--
to a service.
I know how to authenticate it.
I know how to make requests.
What I don't know
is how to manage
my success as a developer,
because if I want to deploy
this, I have a real project.
I'm going to have to
manage that in some way.
For that, we have
David Gibson here,
who will continue the talk,
and he will explain that
in all the detail
you need to know.
Thank you.
[applause]
Gibson: Hi, I'm David,
and I'm here to tell you
about the rest of your life.
And, uh, the rest of your life,
as you know,
once you've built the app,
there's still--
well, most of your time
is spent managing it
and making sure
that it keeps on working.
Um,
I've been working in
the API infrastructure group
on various, uh,
developer-centric features,
um, on the infrastructure side,
and the way it gets exposed
is in terms
of all the various
project management features.
Um, the story is gonna involve
talking about signup,
talking about access
in a bit more detail,
and then talking about, uh,
our various traffic controls.
So, uh, signup.
Signup really means that
you're becoming
a partner with Google
in serving Google services
to the users of the web.
Our, uh, combined mission,
as it were,
is to make the web better
for everybody,
and, um, what this means
in practice
is that you get various tools
to track how your app is doing,
and also that Google
gets to know who you are,
so that we can reach out to you
if there are problems,
and we can reach out to you
if there's new features
or changes that you
should be aware of.
Um, it also means that
we get to serve traffic to you,
and not the bad guys.
There are, unfortunately,
a lot of people out there
who are trying to do things
like, uh,
search for every single
restaurant in Europe,
and that's not a good use
of anybody's resources.
So, uh, we'd rather
be serving traffic to people
who are serving
real user use cases.
Okay, signup sounds
a bit complicated,
but actually it's very easy.
Tony's walked you through
the entire flow already.
All you need
is a Google account,
and you select the APIs
you want to use,
you accept the terms of service,
and you're done.
You're good to go.
Um, when you want
to go back to the console,
you'll see there's a whole
lot more features there.
You can invite other
team members for either,
you know, read-only access,
or actually edit access
to your project,
and you can set up
access credentials
and you can manage
the traffic controls.
Now I do want to talk about
terms of service
a little bit more.
Okay, I'm an engineer trying
to sound like a lawyer here,
but it's actually not true
that the lawyers made us do it.
It's actually more true
that we made the lawyers do it,
and we very much
want to encode
the responsibilities
on both sides here.
We want to make sure
that neither
Google developers or Google
suddenly gets a surprise
and gets subjected
to something
they weren't expecting.
So I do encourage
you to read it.
You only need to read it once,
and, in fact,
the console will only
ever show it to you once.
Um, and as you read it, bear in
mind that the motivation for it
is to improve the web experience
for the end users.
Okay,
enough about signup.
Now, um, Tony started talking
about access,
and I want to cover it
in a bit more detail.
Um, there are only
two separate purposes
for which you're gonna need
to identify yourself,
and that's to access
Google services,
and then to access,
uh, user data,
with the user's permission,
of course.
And these are usually called
the 2-legged
and the 3-legged cases.
In the first case, there's two
legs--it's just you and Google.
In the second case, there's
you, Google and the user
who are all entering
into a relationship.
Um, you may ask,
"What if you don't identify
yourself at all?"
And, yes, you can experiment
completely anonymously.
Um, don't expect to be able
to launch
your app anonymously.
Um, you'll find
that as you experiment,
you're gonna get
limited service access.
Um, some APIs don't want you
to experiment anonymously
at all, unfortunately.
Um, most APIs are gonna
grant you a pretty low QPS
for experimentation purposes,
and, of course,
uh, don't expect to access
user's private data
if the user doesn't know
who you are.
Um,
let's go to the simple
API access case,
where it's just you wanting
to access a Google service.
All it needs is an API key...
And it's designed
to be Grab and Go,
very simple to grab and deploy.
Here's an example.
Um, here's
the URL shortener application
with the key
at the end of the URL,
and, in fact, I encourage you
to click on this link now.
Um, this link here is the same
as the long link above,
and it calls
the URL shortener with that key,
and we get the same result
as before.
Uh, I encourage you
to click on it now,
because we're gonna get
back to that a bit later.
One other thing to mention here
is that the security
is pretty simple.
It's what you see here.
It's a shared secret.
If you are accessing this
from your server,
call us with HTTPS, and, uh,
don't let anybody else
access your server.
If you're calling it
from the browser,
it's obviously on the open web,
but you can lock it to just
the referrer of your site,
and I'll show you
how to do that.
The 3-legged case now--
Tony has covered
most of this already.
I do want to point out
on the side here,
that both the keys
and the secrets
can be revoked at any time
should you suspect
that someone is abusing it
or, uh,
you just want to change
your secrets, you know?
This is like a password,
and they say that, uh,
you know, passwords
are like underwear, you know.
You should keep them secret
and change them often.
[laughter]
Gibson: So the OAuth2 story--
what we are trying to avoid here
is expecting users
to give their password to you
when all you want to do
is access their Buzz feed.
The password is too powerful
a credential to hand over...
So it consists of three steps,
and the first step is really
the most important.
This is what the user will see.
It's the permission dialogue.
And knowing most users,
they're gonna see it
and click "allow" immediately
without really reading it,
but let's look at it
in a bit more detail.
Mark's shown you this already,
with viewing your URLs,
and it's actually got the e-mail
of you, the developer,
and it has the URL,
including the site name,
of your site,
which gives the users something
that they can, you know,
identify with and decide whether
they're going to trust or not.
Once they've consented,
the rest of the flow
is behind the scenes.
Um, because there are various
different use cases,
the flows, as they are called,
are slightly different.
From JavaScript,
there's an access token.
I think, after a pound sign,
there's a web server flow.
There's a local server flow,
which is what Tony was showing.
And step 3 is what
you really wanted to do,
which was to access
the user's data,
and you put a token in the URL,
and that token encodes
who you are and who the user is,
and you get the user's data.
And there's actually a step 4,
which is that
the user themselves
may, at some point, decide that
they don't like you anymore,
or they want to clean up their--
who they've granted
permission to.
They can go to
the console google.com page,
and as you see here,
this user has granted access
to the URL shortener--
to the API Explorer and the URL
shortener, in particular,
and they can
evoke access instantly.
This is a very quick tour
of OAuth.
There will be a talk tomorrow,
um, 1:45,
covering a lot of these topics
in a lot more detail.
So we've covered
two of the three points.
Uh, signup you should only
really need to do once.
The access you should,
hopefully, only need to do once,
but you might need to revoke
your keys at some point.
The traffic controls you might
want to monitor continuously,
on perhaps a daily
or weekly basis.
So with all these new APIs then,
we have, uh, default
daily limits set up
per day, per application.
Um, the limits are fairly large.
They are sufficient for many,
you know,
small- to moderate-sized sites.
For the case of Buzz
and URL shortener,
it's a million queries a day,
which should be enough
for a lot of sites.
That said, more is available
on request,
if you actually fill in a form
and let us know who you are,
and your use case, we are more
than happy to grant you more--
um, academic users,
in particular.
And lastly, we are going to be--
we are introducing
some billable APIs, as well.
First out of the gate
are Custom Search
and Prediction.
Now we get back to the point
that this is
a shared responsibility
between Google
and you the developer,
in that while we grant your
entire app for daily quota
users could still
accidentally, or on purpose,
exhaust your entire quota
if they hit you hard enough,
because it is shared
among all your users.
So you get to decide,
based on the kind of traffic
that your app has,
whether you want to set
a high query-per-second rate
for each individual user IP
or not.
Um, if your app
is particularly "bursty,"
you want to set that high.
If your app users are only gonna
access once or twice per day,
then you can set that limit low.
It all depends on
your traffic patterns.
You may ask, "What if your users
are querying your server,
and your server is relaying
that request to Google?
And we have thought of that.
There's a very simple way
of just putting that user's IP
in the request URL,
and Google will do all the, uh,
metering on your behalf.
Now lastly, um, billable APIs.
When, um, there are
large sites out there
querying Google,
they do and can't--
will eventually incur
real serving costs to us,
and, uh, well there's two
real ways for dealing with this,
and one is, yeah,
as I've mentioned,
you--you set limits.
The other one is you do
the obvious business thing,
and you start charging
for Google's costs.
This, uh, payment system
is also, if you think about it,
a way to improve
the quality bar.
It becomes, uh,
a lightweight relationship,
lightweight
business relationship
between developers and Google,
and Google is providing
a quantifiable commitment
that, uh, these APIs
are gonna be there,
and are worth something,
and, uh,
it enforces quality
on both sides in that way.
The, uh, actual signup process
is very simple.
You--you sign up
with a credit card
in the API console.
You get to choose
a daily maximum,
because, after all,
it's your money.
You decide how many queries
a day you will tolerate,
and, uh, the API infrastructure
will enforce that.
It's important to mention
that all APIs in the project
get the same--
will get the billable limits,
so, uh, you should really
keep two projects around--
one for, you know,
experimentation
and development work,
and one for production,
where, you know,
money's gonna be charged.
And then you'll get a monthly
bill through Google checkout
in a pretty familiar mechanism.
Okay, it is now time for, uh,
a bit of demo,
and walking through
a few of these features.
Here's that, uh, URL again.
Um, try and hit that...
application,
and I'll show you what happens
in the console.
Let's try the development link.
So on this project here,
it's a traffic control screen.
It's--it's currently
accepting requests
from any referrer,
which means that your requests
should be going through--
and we're gonna verify
and reload here--
yes, they are still
going through.
But if I reconfigure this,
I can say, well, actually,
yes, I want it
from browser scripts,
and we can,
you know,
pretend I own that site.
If anybody actually
owns that site, speak up.
But we update that,
and, uh, it takes, uh,
a minute or two
for caches to clear,
but if you were hitting
that URL--
we'll give it a few minutes
while I--
while I talk about
other things--
that access should be
shut down for anybody
except people coming
from that site.
So there are per-user limits,
which I had talked about.
The URL shortener is set
fairly low,
which we don't expect
users to hit much.
Now--and there's the limit
of 1,000--
a million queries a day
for the URL shortener.
Now if we were
to turn on Billing--
let's do that, we'll go
to the production project.
It would look like this.
So URL shortener, it doesn't
have a billable limit,
so you get the million,
and the Custom Search API,
which does, has increased
to, uh, 1,000 queries a day.
Let us verify that.
Okay, well, I need to talk
more slowly,
and eventually,
access here will be blocked.
Um, I do not exactly have time
to talk more slowly,
so experiment with this
on your own.
The last thing I want
to show you, though,
is that...
Based on the traffic,
you can see that--
and if you hit--
start hitting that URL more,
uh,
there it is again--
Nhm7a.
You can see me experimenting
in the week before
the conference,
and you can see that traffic
is starting to spike today,
and these graphs are real time
up to less than a minute,
and this is starting
to offer you tracking.
It's starting to offer you
simple analytics.
In this case, there's referrer
base and different APIs,
you know,
translator's gonna show you
breakdown by language
and things like that,
and you can track to see how
close you're coming to quota,
and what kind of users
are reaching your site.
Has the numbers
actually changed?
No, it hasn't actually
changed, okay.
All right,
that is the end of my very brief
tour of the console.
I'm gonna hand back to Mark
to sum up.
Stahl: So...
Gibson: Thank you.
[applause]
Stahl: Thanks a lot
to the engineers,
who do a lot of this great,
great work for you guys.
So, uh, you've now seen
pretty much, uh, what--
this is pretty much
what you need
to get started as a developer,
Google APIs.
We have built a lot of new
technology, just to wrap up.
We have the APIs Explorer,
so if you're in that
"get inspired" learning stage,
this is a great first step
to stake--just go and play.
They're all there waiting
for you to try them out.
Uh, if you want to start coding,
we've got lots
of client libraries,
so go--and we've been
concentrating heavily.
Our developers have
told us over again
that they really like samples.
Uh, that's how a lot
of people get started.
And so we are concentrating
on our client libraries,
which all follow
the same patterns,
and samples for every API
we can get around to writing,
and all the projects
are open-source,
so if you don't see a sample
and you want to submit one,
you know, we take contributions.
We take donations, you know.
And also we've built
this new API console.
This is where you establish
your relationship to Google.
It's a two-way relationship.
You get a lot
of information back,
and you can manage
all the authentication
and registration procedures,
which traditionally
were very hard for APIs.
They're all centralized
in one place.
All your keys,
all your management--
It's all centralized. You can
change your keys and revoke.
You can monitor your traffic.
You monitor your billing.
Uh, it really, uh,
makes life really easy
for developers to get started.
So, uh, we have just
what's next?
There's a lot more
information here.
First off, uh, the sample
that Tony ran today,
we have actually put the code
up there,
so if you want to build
a URL shortener agent,
well, we built one for you,
um, go ahead, download the code,
see how it works,
try it out yourself.
We did remove all the keys,
so you're gonna
have to add your own,
but, um, since it's--
then it's your project.
Uh, we also have
a lot more APIs.
Google has a huge web site
devoted for developers,
so go check out
the code.google.com APIs link,
or any of the new tools,
obviously, you can go try them.
And more client libraries,
so pick the language
of your choice.
Uh, so this is
to get you guys started.
The Google APIs are a big topic
at, uh, Google I/O.
There's a lot more talks
that you can follow on,
so just a brief rundown of
other places you may want to go
if you want to learn
more about programming--
one, of course, Android.
We have a whole talk today--
I believe it's
just after this one--
that discusses just
the techniques you're gonna need
if you're writing
for Google APIs on Android.
It's a different environment,
but it's the exact same
client library.
Um, different transport--
it all works together.
But if you want to do
Android programming...
We also have built an extension
to the Eclipse environment,
so if you want to work
on a project in Eclipse,
download into Eclipse, uh,
we build a plug-in for that.
There is a talk, uh,
this afternoon on that,
so that's one of the new
features of API support.
Tomorrow, we have a couple--
we have two talks, as well,
that 'm gonna point you to--
First is, we talked about
the new Discovery API,
which we use for building
these client libraries
across all these languages,
so you can go check out on that,
and as David had
already mentioned,
uh, for those who want to really
understand authentication
and how it works, tomorrow,
there's a talk
tomorrow afternoon, as well.
So that's everything we have.
Google APIs are open
for business.
We're looking forward to all
the great apps you guys build.
I'm open for, uh,
questions and answers,
and if, uh, Tony and David
could come up...
[applause]
Stahl: So--thank you.
And just a word,
uh, procedural word,
if you want to ask a question,
if you could please
use the microphone,
so, uh, other people
can hear you.
man: Okay, I've turned on
the multi-factor authentication.
Does that change any of the
flows or the approval screens?
Stahl: I'm sorry, I'm not, uh--
which?
man: I've turned on
the multi-factor authentication
in my Google account.
Does that change
any of the approval screens or
any of the workflow experience?
Aiuto: Oh, no.
Stahl: It--it--multi-factor,
yeah, I know where it actually
does impact--one of the things
we didn't show in this--
in these diagrams,
the web browser was already
logged in as the test user.
And when the web--
when the user logs in,
that's the point
at which they see
the login, username,
password, and 2-factor auth.
The approval dialogue
comes after that.
man: Okay.
Stahl: So this presumes
post 2-factor auth flows.
It's just part of the flow.
Um, does anybody else
have any other questions?
Auito: Sir, over there?
man: Hi, um,
the Python client library--
is that, uh,
App Engine compatible?
Can I build applications
on App Engine?
Aiuto: Yes, it is.
Stahl: Yes, in fact, it's, uh,
one of the interesting parts
about the Python library is, uh,
it's completely dynamic.
Python being a dynamic language,
it literally works
with every API out the door
that comes on the--
that runs off Discovery.
It downloads Discovery,
bills the library on the fly,
and makes it available to you.
Um, so it's--
and the developer's around here
somewhere, you know?
man: [laughs]
Stahl: So it's--it's ready,
and App Engine is one
of its target places,
so it's ready to go.
man: Okay, thanks.
Stahl: Yes?
man: Hi, guys.
Thanks for the talk.
So as a developer, if I,
uh, request a set of services,
and I get, you know,
maybe my apps really good,
and thousands of people grant
access to my application,
and then I add a new feature
at some point,
which now requires,
uh, high--
you know, additional services
that I need access for,
what do I do with all
the existing OAuth tokens?
Do I have to basically
get everybody to re-auth,
or is there a process to sort of
upgrade the existing people?
Stahl: David?
Gibson: Yes, you will need
to re-auth,
because you--you can't, uh,
do anything else
with users' permissions.
You're, you know, violating
their trust if you don't.
man: Right.
Gibson: Um, the OAuth flows,
I believe will do that
completely automatically. If the
user's already authenticated,
it won't show a second dialogue.
If you're adding something,
it'll automatically show
a dialogue to the user again.
man: Okay, all right.
Stahl: This is the exact
same flow you'll notice
in Android applications...
man: Mm-hmm.
Stahl: If a developer, say,
in an Android application,
it's very similar to OAuth,
you declare your required
permissions on the phone.
If the developer upgrades
the set of permissions,
the install dialogue re-shows
and requires them
to re-authenticate.
It's the same with OAuth2.
You have to--
you have to ask
for the permissions you want.
That's really the basis of it.
man: Yep, okay, thanks.
Over there.
man: Hi. Sorry--again.
Um, I don't want to start
a high rest versus low rest
holy war,
but I was slightly surprised
at the result of a post
to the collection,
did return a 201--
uh, created, rather than a 200.
What we're seeing is a 200,
okay,
when you create a new
URL shortener, for example.
Has there been any thought,
um, in that direction?
Stahl: Um, it probably
should be a 201,
but I-I don't know why that's--
that was probably just,
you know, that particular code.
There's no--I would've thought
a 201, as well, as an insert--
oh, I actually know why--
probably because the item
already exists.
We've created--we've shortened
the google.com URL before, so--
man: I see. So it's put.
Stahl: Uh, we could
try it out on that Explorer
and see what happens.
That would be my guess.
Um, and if we have time,
I will, but I'm--
if it's okay with you,
we can get some other questions,
and we can try it out--you can
either try it out on your own,
or we can try it right here.
man: Thank you.
Stahl: Yeah.
man: Uh, do you guys plan
to make changes to the APIs
as you upgrade
them to the new system,
because the Calendar API
is a little bit of a mess
if you want to get
all of the events.
Stahl: [laughs]
Seriously, yes.
[laughs]
man: Yeah.
Stahl: Um, we're not trying
to migrate our services blindly.
man: Okay.
Stahl: We do ask them to rethi--
because a lot of services,
that was their first version,
and as they come on,
uh, they have new versions
and we ask them
to rethink their APIs.
man: Okay.
Stahl: Um, we've
also built, you see,
in the URL structure,
we've built versioning
strongly into the system
to make it easier to support
upgrading versions
in the future, so...
man: Okay.
Stahl: Yeah. If you have
a specific suggestion,
send it to the Calendar dude.
man: Wait to get
all of the, uh, events
from all the Calendars,
instead of having to get
the list of Calendars,
and then every event
from each...
Stahl: Yeah, right.
Aiuto: Anyone else?
Stahl: So do we have
any other questions?
All right.
Uh, thank you very much.
Aiuto: Thanks, guys.
[applause]